quero compartilhar com vocês um sonho
maluco que tinha desde menina ser freira
o problema é que este sonho junta duas
coisas que costumam dar problemas uma à
outra a razão e coração eu nasci numa
ilha que se chama em trilhas no interior
de cametá em belém do pará
meu pai era comerciante minha mãe
costureira sou a 11ª de 14 irmãos
embora tenha nascido nessa ilha que é um
lugar muito simples e com poucos
recursos
tive uma infância muito feliz
o ria e brincava numa imensa praia subir
em árvores para pegar frutas até em
árvores de açaí mas logo cedo aos 8 anos
de idade foi morar com a minha irmã mais
velha que é professora casou e foi morar
numa outra ilha a deixar a poeira também
no interior de cametá
acho que se procurarem no gugu não vou
nem achar
com ela aprende a ler ea escrever
no período em que fui morar com a minha
irmã meus pais mudaram do interior para
a cidade de belém devido à distância
minha mãe sentia muitas saudades de mim
pediu a minha irmã que me levasse de
volta para casa mas foi por pouco tempo
aos 13 anos fui morar com meus tios em
irituia uma pequena cidade do pará
irituia eu tinha uma opção de lazer
a igreja católica latino casarão onde
moravam muitas feiras e elas visitavam
as famílias para saber se estavam bem
foi então que fiquei mais próxima delas
e meu sonho que desde menina era ser
freira para encestar muito perto de se
realizar naquela pequena cidade era
minha porção coração que estava se
concretizando com essa convivência tão
próxima com as freiras
aos 15 anos é irituia conhecia
costureiras e artesãs e comecei a
desenvolver o meu lado empreendedor
costurava roupas infantis para as
crianças que moravam na roça como
pagamento eu ganhava há aves e ovos
bananas peixe castanha do pará e outros
frutos da região
neste momento já era a razão funcionando
e se desenvolvendo
enquanto isso o coração se encantava
pela vida religiosa aos 15 anos de idade
retornei à casa dos meus pais para
continuar os estudos em belém
comecei a participar de um grupo jovem
da igreja católica
arranjei um namorado ganhei o primeiro
beijo aconteceu momento maysa meu mundo
caiu em desistir de ser freira quando
tinha uns 18 anos sem nunca ter sofrido
bullying
comecei a sentir um complexo de
inferioridade e achava tão feia
pensava que as pessoas não gostavam da
minha companhia
isso veio do nada e de repente me sentia
como um peixe fora d'água
vejam só meu nome é bellizia que é de
origem latina que está ligado à
sensibilidade simpatia cooperação e
diplomacia como alguém com estas
características poderiam se sentir tão
rejeitada pois é somos complexas assim
acreditam que quando estava no ônibus
jamais sentava ao lado de alguém tinha
sempre a sensação de estar sendo
inconveniente de alguma maneira se
preciso e em pé toda amassada mas não
sentava
foi um período bem difícil para superar
esse desconforto não precisei de
psicólogo
comecei a prestar atenção nas coisas
boas que as pessoas falavam meu respeito
devagarinho minha auto-estima começou a
ir para um lugar até que vence o tal
complexo de inferioridade
aos 19 anos foi trabalhar em uma loja de
eletrodomésticos para ajudar meus pais
após dois anos na empresa pedir demissão
e vim para o rio de janeiro
assim que cheguei aqui no rio por ter
experiência com vendas foi trabalhar em
uma loja de produtos diversos
casei tive dois filhos me separei por
motivo de ciúme doentio palavras
ofensivas e de intensas humilhações
após a minha separação foi trabalhar no
setor de internação e de um hospital foi
então neste hospital que surgiu a idéia
de um novo empreendimento
eu tinha que confeccionar o meu próprio
uniforme
sempre que chegava com meu uniforme
as colegas de serviço perguntava quem
fez este uniforme rindo
respondi dia eu que fiz
começaram as primeiras encomendas do
hospital
depois vieram confecções de roupas
concertos aos quais aprendi sozinha
nesse momento tomei consciência de que
já na cera adornada com esse dom dom
maravilhoso que é a modelagem ea costura
agarrei com total dedicação
a partir daí iniciei um trabalho de
corte e costura para complementar a
renda do lar
só que no auge das encomendas
eu trabalhei mais com o coração isso
quer dizer que na maioria das vezes
não cobrava pelo meu trabalho não achava
correto cobrar por um simples que tipo
de roupa estava misturando o ser
empreendedora ao meu lado não realizado
de freira com sinônimo de caridade
caridade mais sutil fu era minha baixa
autoestima dando as caras novamente
fiquei vários anos trabalhando mais com
o coração do que com a razão
em 2003 sofreu um acidente de carro
ao receber os atendimentos pela equipe
de saúde houve a necessidade de
permanecer internada para fazer alguns
exames onde se descobriu um problema e
que precisaria operar nesse momento
precisa interromper minhas atividades
laborais inclusive o trabalho de costura
para me preparar enfrentar a cirurgia
um dia ao sair para fazer o exame de
biópsia ou não conseguir realizar porque
estava com a pressão arterial elevada
ao voltar para casa resolvi caminhando
até a estação de trem meio triste e
preocupada com a minha saúde e com o meu
trabalho de costura que estava parado
passei em frente a um brechó de roupas e
acessórios femininos
entrei conversei um pouco e aproveitei
para oferecer o melhor serviço sabe um
dia se ela precisasse e eu pudesse
pois não é que depois de alguns meses
ela me telefonou
eu já estava recuperada cheia de saúde e
vontade de trabalhar e precisando muito
de uma graninha
ela estava me fazendo uma proposta de
trabalho para que o confeccionasse
artesanatos para uma loja que seria
inaugurada na zona sul do rio de janeiro
gente vocês já imaginaram de em trilhas
lado interior
tá no estado do pará para a zona sul do
rio de janeiro
fiquei numa emoção de botar o coração
pra correr só tinha um problema que
ninguém sabia eu nunca havia feito
artesanato na vida mas lá vou eu deixar
uma oferta dessa no ar
aceitei o desafio e falei claro minha
querida deixa comigo vou fazer umas
peças lindas que você vai vender muito
na zona sul
naquele momento eu estava confiando no
meu potencial era minha autoestima de
volta
acreditava que faria o meu melhor para
dar tudo certo agora aqui entre nós
modestamente falando fiz e foi um grande
sucesso
vendi muitas peças minha autoestima foi
para o lugar
infelizmente minha amiga precisou fechar
a loja
mas até aí o milagre já tinha acontecido
esse desafio
o impulso no com o sangue fervendo pelo
artesanato
abracei a idéia de me tornar uma artesã
e de trabalhar com a razão
finalmente tinha conseguido um caminho
que juntasse a razão com o coração o
coração faz cria faz o design criar
minhas peças a razão bota pra vender nas
feiras da cidade e de onde mas tiver
espaço razão ganhar meu sustento emoção
fazendo alguma coisa que me dê profundo
prazer tudo foi possível a partir do
momento em que superei os obstáculos
o principal deles dentro de mim mesma
passei a acreditar na minha capacidade
permitindo minha autoestima se expandir
e fazer com que as minhas mãos traduzam
meu sonho
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
ó